hello and thanks for being with us sinn
fein an irish nationalist party is on
course to become the largest party in
the northern ireland assembly for the
first time in a century now a unionist
party has always taken the most seats
since the formation of northern ireland
in 1921
a historic wind fishing vein could set
the stage for a border pole a referendum
on a unified island
now the counting of ballots has been
paused and will resume at 9 00 am around
half of the 90 seats have been filled so
far
well our senior island correspondent
david blevins centers this report and a
warning it does contain flash
photography from the start and
throughout
they sense a shift in the governance of
northern ireland a political earthquake
for the united kingdom
[Applause]
the result raises the prospect of a vote
on irish unity shin fein on course to
nominate a first minister
well there's still a way to go yet david
but obviously it's a very significant
election for many reasons and
the people have responded to our
positive campaign a very positive
message and it's now time to get almost
permanent executive and delivering for
people
the sea border between great britain and
northern ireland the consequence of
brexit has fractured the unionist vote
but the democratic unionists were not
conceding defeat they know there can't
be a power sharing government without
them we need the long shadow of the
protocol removed from the political
institutions in northern it is creating
untold harm to northern ireland and it
needs to be dealt with uh and it must be
dealt with and uh the government need to
hear that message very loud and clear
shinton did better than it could the dup
not as badly as it feared
one of the big stories of this election
is the quiet revolution that's taking
place in the middle ground while it's
clear many people are still voting along
traditional lines a growing number are
choosing not to vote unionist or
nationalist but for a completely new
type of politics here
the alliance party could double its
representation a clear signal from a
weary electorate precious little hope um
available for people at the minute it's
been a pretty grim couple of years and
the politics has been pretty grim to
match it we just offered people i think
hope that things could be better and
that's what we want to deliver on
brexit had already placed the
constitutional question on the table but
will sinn fein now demand a referendum
on irish unity
the conversation around the unity place
has been
forced right into the fore for quite a
considerable period of time that was
always going to be the outcome that's
going to continue the other side of this
election regardless of the outcome if
northern ireland has elected a first
minister whose party doesn't want
northern ireland to exist
it's a defining moment
david levin's sky news in belfast
well let's bring in now the education
secretary nadim sahari is joining us
live from westminster good morning to
you mr zaha we thanks for being with us
this morning let's just pick up on what
we saw a little bit in david blevins
report of course uh counting is is gonna
resume in northern ireland in uh an hour
or so two hours time how will a uk
government deal with the fact that shin
fein are about to be the largest party
in the northern ireland assembly
well i think it's important to wait uh
and see the final result uh the the big
uh
focus has to be on
making sure we get the protocol uh to
work i think jeffrey donson was right
on that clip that you just showed
but let's wait and see the final result
uh of course uh clearly the uh
predictions that champaign uh has done
well uh but of course the unionist
parties uh collectively um uh are also
um uh you know
a significant part of this vote and uh
the uh other parties as well the
alliance party and so on uh the
important focus i know from the
secretary of state for northern ireland
is to make sure
that um
the protocol
works
and is fixed
as soon as possible
because clearly it is an issue
for
the people of northern ireland and it's
the right thing for us to be focused on
yeah let's pick up a couple of those
points and uh that protocol sir jeffrey
donaldson says that he basically wants
it just torn up is that something the uk
government would do
well as
brandon lewis the um northern ireland
secretary said um that you know all
options remain on the table
uh the important thing is to try and
make sure
we
work
with uh the uh parties in northern
ireland but also with the uh european
commission
to make um you know
to make sure that we leave no stone
unturned uh to try and make it work uh
but of course you know we we we need to
make sure that that all our options are
available to us because ultimately uh
the thing to remember
is uh northern ireland is very much part
of the family that is the united kingdom
i mean just on that then i mean of
course fine words uh all options on the
table but you are going to with whatever
decision is made upset someone in this
particular decision be it's the
unionists in ireland or the eu which
ones are you going to upset well i don't
think
it's a trade-off i think the important
thing is that we uh put the people of
northern ireland front and center if
that is um uh
what we do as our priority and we
evidence this then all sides whether
it's the eu
or ourselves should be working towards
making
the lives of people northern ireland um
much much better and
for them to see
that both the eu
and the uk government are working
together to get the right
outcome ultimately if you if you put
them as as
as the the the people that we want to
make sure
we deliver for uh all communities then i
think it's right to try and work as hard
as we can
to deliver for them and make the
protocol
work
that is our priority that is what the
northern sector will do
but at the same time he will not
compromise on um uh you know making sure
that that northern ireland is very much
part of the united kingdom yeah i mean
you've had years to do that so you'll
forgive viewers for not being convinced
that it can be done but let's move on to
the local elections on this island
the conservative party of lost nearly
500 council seats
simple question is boris johnson still
an electoral asset for the conservatives
so if you look at
the local elections and and you have to
remember um we are in mid-term uh coming
out of the covered pandemic into a
global battle against inflation with
energy prices now spiking because of the
illegal war in the ukraine
take london
for example of course i was out
campaigning in wandsworth and um we lost
wandsworth and of course
marginally lost westminster as well but
we gained harrow
in london and so it's important that we
listen to our candidates to our
very good counsellors of course the ones
that succeeded in the ones that didn't
but look at other parts of the country
non-eaton uh newcastle underlined first
time uh where the conservatives in 25
years now have control of newcastle
underline um
this has not been a good uh night for uh
sakir stama um in terms of going forward
this is a a result from a local election
where we are in midterm out of a
pandemic and of course
battling a you know this global battle
against inflation and so it's right that
people um
were concerned there are some local
issues that we have to address as well
as national issues and we'll listen to
those we will not be complacent we'll
listen to what people are telling us and
we must do better and of course
you've got the queen's speech next week
and you'll see
what we're bringing forward is a plan
for jobs a plan for the economy a plan
to deal with the backlog in the nhs and
of course make sure that national
security both abroad with war in europe
and at home are front and center
controlling our borders of course is
very much part of that national security
plan yeah i mean i didn't hear you say
that he was an asset let me put it to
you he is an asset absolutely i i know i
was really trying i was trying to give
you some of the evidence uh
of of what i think happened with the
local elections uh but you know you look
at the way boris cuts through in uh
places like non-eaton places like
newcastle underline other parts of the
country as well harrow in london other
parts of the country
sorry let me just get my next question
because other parts of the country is
exactly right isn't it because the
tories have been wiped out in wales
moved into third place in scotland so
you're happy just being a party for
english people right well
let's take your point about scotland in
2017
um scotland we had 115
councillors went up to
275 councils so over doubled so we
already had a very high bar in scotland
um now
when you start from such a high bar
you're bound to look at maybe losing
some seats
there but of course we're not going to
be complacent we want to make sure that
we deal with some of the national issues
like the global battle against inflation
and of course the local issues as well
uh but i i don't recognize your
characterization that you know we've
been wiped out in scotland that's not
true no no sorry it wiped out in wales
because you lost the only council that
you held one of the shows went to no
overall control
and we will try much harder to make sure
that we deal with those issues including
the the investment that's going into
wales of things like nuclear renewables
and of course you know other investments
that we're making uh in wales um
this is this this is a mid-term local
election that we have to listen to the
voters on and have to continue to
deliver but we have a plan for jobs we
have a plan for the economy a plan to
deal with the nhs backlog and of course
make sure that our borders are secure um
and and
deal with war in in europe and all these
things boris johnson is dealing with uh
let me put it to you this way then after
all the issues that have
faced this government and the prime
minister especially being fined and
having to deal with politicians watching
pornography in the house of commons
there were some of your colleagues who
up to these elections were saying that
this will be a moment this will be a
test of the prime minister and whether
we want to go on with him are you happy
that he's passed that test and you're
happy to go on with him all your
colleagues in agreement with that well
my message to all of my colleagues and i
stood in 1997
in iran and thamesbeat in south london
and i can tell you that people don't
like to vote for
split parties for for teams that are
divided and we are strongest when we are
united we've got a queen speech next
week where we will demonstrate to the
nation that the second half of this
parliament is all about dealing with uh
repairing the economy recovering from
covert as i've just talked about the
backlog of the nhs and of course
national security here at home
safer streets and of course abroad
all these things we have a plan for it's
yeah as i say we're stronger when we are
united and that'll be my message to all
my colleagues and you look at where we
are making ground in in uh places like
uh the west midlands in in non-eton and
of course newcastle underlined
people want to see us focus not on um
issues like partygate by the way secure
stamina i think one in three of his
questions at question time were on on
parties yeah and actually neglecting
cost of living
and of course people see the hypocrisy
of that now you've seen the headlines
this morning
i will i'll put those points to the
labour party right now i'm sure i'm sure
you will i'm sure
i'm just saying i'm just reflecting on
public opinion people will will look at
that and we'll be uncomfortable with the
hypocrisy and the police have now
obviously have to carry out their
investigation and let's see where that
ends up yeah absolutely we will do uh um
and then finally there mrs we you talk
about making making changes
all the indications are that in the uh
um autumn budget there will be some help
for the cousin but people are really
dealing with all of that now why is the
party putting off trying to help
hard-working families who are really
struggling to make ends meet through the
summer just to try and do it in the
autumn well i don't think that's uh
correct with respect uh we're not
holding up with the chances of putting
22 billion pounds in the next 12 months
because he recognizes that we're in a
global battle against inflation as is in
america as in the rest of uh europe uh
with high inflation at the moment
spiking because of energy costs 22
billion so let's try and unpack some of
that um you look at the
taper relief if people are on universal
credit that's an an extra thousand
pounds for those people because of that
relief the national living wage that's
another thousand pounds and then of
course the national insurance
changes he made uh
in terms of the threshold that's another
330 pounds a year for the most uh you
know
people who are under pressure because of
high energy costs because of high
utility bills and of course we'll
continue to review that continue to look
at that a billion pounds going to local
government who know that who those
people are who are struggling with their
weekly shop who are struggling with
their uh utility bills
all that is 22 billion in 12 months uh
because the chancellor's is well aware
of the pressure that people are under at
the moment because of the spike uh in
energy costs and of course the global
fight against inflation yes it's a hell
of a list of things though isn't it mr
harwin it's very very expensive i mean
reports from the um governor of the bank
of england saying that we're heading
towards recession people's uh bank
balance is really struggling to make
ends meet um where are you on this idea
of a windfall tax on energy firms we saw
shells profits the other day huge
so i think a couple of things on that
one we need to make sure we get the
investment in our gas assets in the
north sea
because clearly mr sahara you know that
the bosses of these companies have said
they will keep investing even if they
are taxed more right so so
we need to make sure that investment
happens both
well just just hear me out a second both
shell and bp have announced i know shell
25 billion in renewables bp a similar
number in hydrogen and in renewables to
meet um you know those those important
targets of net zero by 2050 to make sure
that we preserve uh this precious planet
and of course one last thing to remember
is both shell and bp pay double the
corporation tax that other companies pay
so corporation tax for them is about 40
percent uh at the moment if we want that
investment if we want in in renewables
in of course getting our gas assets so
that actually we don't uh rely on other
countries for the gas that we're going
to need anyway even if you're going to
we're going to move to to a hydrogen
economy you still need gas in that
economy those those are the things that
are important and of course the help
that we are putting in 22 billion over
the next 12 months all of that is the
right thing to do when the
pandemic hit bo shell and bp
lost billions of pounds that is
pensioners money that is pension funds
pensioners rely on those profits to be
able uh to to to make sure that they uh
can uh live well and uh pay for the
things they need to pay for so we have
to look at this in the round and be
responsible we have a plan for the
economy we have a plan for jobs labor
doesn't
okay mr zahwe do appreciate your time
this morning and putting your point
across really good to talk to you
thank you
all right now let's move to the war in
ukraine and ukraine's president vladimir
zelinsky says that diplomatic efforts
are underway to save the remaining
fighters who are still holed up inside
the as of style steel works in mario
paul let's bring in our security and
defense editor deborah hayes joining us
from the ukrainian capital kiev this
morning good morning to you deborah so
bring us up to speed what do we know
about what's happening right now in
mario paul around as of star
well it's still this um incredible
standoff at that plant it's become
really a symbol of ukraine's resistance
given that mariupol the surrounding city
has been at the heart of the war in
terms of bombardments besieging
civilians killed uh and yet this
hardcore this final core of ukrainian
fighters holed up in the azov style
steel works have managed to
endure this russian pressure they've
resisted
russian offers to surrender to walk out
um there's no trust on either side as
well it must be said in terms of trying
to end this siege and also in the steel
works you have had
since the beginning of the war frankly
civilians sheltering there the
steelworks itself is this vast complex
that stretches over more than four
square miles and underneath the ground
there is effectively a city of tunnels
of reinforced bunkers you couldn't
design a better fortress and the there
was also a lot of stores under there to
enable people to shelter from the
bombardments which is what they've done
but of course those stores are running
very have run out
food supply is very very limited and
that's why there has been this critical
effort from the highest level of the
international community including the
head of the united nations the red cross
is involved the pope is involved trying
first of all to extract civilians and we
did have uh
remarkably 50 more women children and
elderly evacuating from the rubble of
that plant yesterday um
the idea to get all of the remaining
civilians that we don't know exactly how
many more there could be uh probably a
few dozen then there are also hundreds
of wounded ukrainian fighters there
trying to get them out as well is of an
urgent uh priority and as well as that
the ukrainian president has said that
there are negotiations underway to try
to get the remaining ukrainian fighters
out of there they have withstood as i've
said the russian offensive but they've
also ensured that russia has not been
able fully to declare victory over
mariupol and that's clearly
an irritation and it's also potentially
something that russia might want to
achieve by the 9th of may which is
monday uh the annual victory day in
moscow that would be a symbolic moment
to be able to declare that but equally
for the ukrainians the longer they're
able to hold out there the more they're
able to frustrate russia's plans
absolutely right not long to go until
the 9th of may deborah in kiev thank you
so much for that
now of course a war zone is no place for
the vulnerable and no place for the sick
and had a cancer ward of ukrainian
children's hospital doctors there are
planning an evacuation well our katerino
pitoci spent time with some children
there who have cancer and need to
receive life-saving treatment she sent
us this from the western ukrainian city
of lev
inside levitt's children's hospital
doctors are planning an operation that
is as delicate as it is tough
they've tried to protect patients taping
windows to stop them shattering and
shelling
but now they will attempt the almost
impossible a group evacuation across
international borders from the cancer
ward we are responsible for this kids
yes this is
400 kids so we're responsible for them
so yes of course a lot of pressure yes
there is a pressure
and it has to happen fast war has
disrupted drug supply for those that
need it most
ukraine right now is no place for the
vulnerable
do you need to go now
okay for the third time today there's an
air raid warning
the sick scramble to the basement
shelter
one of the strangest we've ever seen
the hospital has a disused spa in the
basement built originally for
high-ranking soviet officials
saunas
and a swimming pool built as luxuries
for russian leaders
now protect
terrified families
[Music]
this is why they have to leave
but on evacuation day things are
incredibly tense
we've got about five minutes until the
convoy is meant to leave now and as you
can see the families they're ready
they're packed but inside there's still
phone calls there's still messages to
try and work out actually where
eventually these families and these
children are going to end up
beyond a first stop at a clinic in
poland families still don't know what
hospital what country they will be taken
to
you feel afraid
why why why are you feeling so
frightened
across the boat
war has stripped families of certainty
control
of each other
wherever they go fathers are unable to
travel
men are fighting age cannot leave
ukraine
these are precious final moments
it's heartbreaking
but vital
finally everyone is on board
families start a journey that will make
them refugees
but could save their lives
caterina for totsi sky news in levitt
ukraine
well this weekend we're going to bring
you a new documentary all about the
refugee crisis in ukraine caused by the
war you can watch it for the first time
today at half past three and there you
can see the other timings of it are on
your screen right now
now it is a deal said to be worth up to
four billion pounds the u.s businessman
todd burley has signed an agreement to
buy chelsea football club in a takeover
that will see the end of roman
abramovich's time in charge now chelsea
was put up for sale by mr abramovic just
days before he was sanctioned by the uk
government for his ties to president
vladimir putin well our reporter sadia
chaudhary is outside the chelsea stadium
at stanford bridge this morning for more
on this sadia thanks for being with us
again so have we finally come to a
conclusion of this chelsea sale
yeah and it does bring to an end the
abramovich era as you say but it also
brings to an end those special measures
that chelsea are having to operate under
which ban it from buying new players or
renewing existing contracts which at
this particular time of the season is of
importance now as you say the deal is
worth 4.25 billion pounds and it means
chelsea goes to a consortium led by the
american billionaire ted bowley he owns
the major league baseball side la
dodgers and he's in the country right
now and is expected to be at the game
this afternoon when chelsea play against
wolves
now if you remember at the uh at start
of march roman abramovich agreed to sell
the club
and just after that he was sanctioned by
the uk government for having ties to
president vladimir putin of russia now
that led to a flurry of investors trying
to buy this club but also questions
about where that money would go roman
abramovich has said that the money the
proceeds would go to charity but there
was a question over a 1.5 billion pound
loan that chelsea football club owes to
abramovich and questions over whether or
not the new pay
the new owners would have to pay that we
can read out a statement from chelsea
football club which hopes to clarify
that i'll read it out to you now it says
2.5 billion pounds will be applied to
purchase the shares in the club and such
proceeds will be deposited into a frozen
uk bank account with the intention to
donate 100 to charitable causes as
confirmed by roman abramovich uk
government approval will be required for
the proceeds to be transferred
from the uk bank account
now that implies that none of that money
will go to ibranovic and for the deal to
go through it needs both the premier
league and uk government approval and
chelsea football club will be hoping
that that happens very quickly because
on the 31st of may that license that
it's currently operating under will
expire and of course we know the june
transfer window opens on the 10th of
june and chelsea will be hoping to make
good use of that this summer
let's return to our top story shin fame
an irish nationalist party they're on
course to become the largest party in
the northern ireland assembly for the
first time in a century now a historic
wind fortune fame could set the stage
for a border pole a referendum on a
unified island well earlier i was able
to speak to the education secretary
nadim sahawi on what all of this could
mean for the future of the northern
ireland protocol
all options remain on the table
the important thing is to try and make
sure
we
work
with
the
parties in northern ireland but also
with the
european commission
to make
um you know
to make sure that we leave no stone
unturned um to try and make it work uh
but of course you know we we need to
make sure that that
all our options are available to us
because ultimately uh the thing to
remember
is uh northern ireland is very much part
of the family that is the united kingdom
let's bring in our political
correspondent rob powell joining us now
live from westminster hello again to you
rob dean saharawi they're saying that
all options are on the table but i did
put it to him he's gonna have to upset
someone and he seemed to still try and
plow a middle path
yeah and i think specifically you'd
asked him a question when he said all
options were on the table of whether the
government could consider ripping up the
northern ireland protocol
entirely so clearly that nuclear option
um is still there that is what the dup
um have been demanding they of course
collapsed power sharing um in stormont
over the northern ireland protocol that
part of the brexit deal that basically
puts a trade border down the irish sea
between northern ireland and the rest of
the uk i think the difficulty is and
we'll have to wait we may get an
indication in the queen's speech next
week when the government lays out its
plans for legislation for the coming
session and we may get an indication in
that of what the government intends to
do
but as you suggest there i think if it
moves towards doing something the dup
would like and rewriting the brexit deal
parts of the northern ireland protocol
on its own what it risks doing is
angering sinn fein which by that point
most likely will be the largest party in
the devolved assembly and they have said
that the northern ireland protocol needs
to be
adhered to so i think brexit and
politics in northern ireland once again
coming into a tricky mix nadim zahawi
also when he was asked about the results
in england scotland and wales and
disappointing results and losses for the
conservatives insisted he still thought
boris johnson was an electoral asset but
did also said they needed to listen to
councillors on local and national issues
and needed to do better absolutely right
okay rob for now thank you so much
for that well let's get some more on the
situation in northern ireland and
bringing the uh editor of the political
website
uh apologies actually the the line to
mcfielty is not quite ready yet so let's
move on some other news uh quickly and i
think we're going to go now to the
situation in sri lanka now there have
been a weeks of protests there and the
president has just declared a state of
emergency now while this has been
happening the former energy minister has
told us here at sky news that his
country is about to run out of food and
fuel
now the protests have been attempted to
be put down by police who use tear gas
and water cannon in an effort to break
up the crowds now people in sri lanka
all across the country are hugely angry
at a rise in the cost of everyday goods
some of them are up at least 30 percent
on the cost of last year now the price
of fuel has also soared petrol is said
to be up 90
and the price of diesel well that's up
138
now the country's current finance
minister said that 3.2 billion pounds is
going to be needed to continue importing
daily essentials let's bring in paul
kelso who is live for us in the lincoln
capital colombo so paul sryanka really
going through
economic turmoil right now what are
people that you've been able to speak to
they're telling you about the situation
in the country
well
part of the opposition to the government
particularly to the president the prime
minister who our brothers is here uh
just in front of the president's office
that's the old parliament building
behind me there this camp has been here
for a month now and they are demanding
change because sri lanka is sliding into
an economic crisis it's foreign currency
reserves are almost exhausted and food
and fuel could be the next things to run
out they've woken up this morning
in a state of emergency as the president
seeks to suppress domestic protest that
yesterday saw thousands of people take
to the streets for a general strike
and paul that's uh that general strike
has been called and we've seen from some
of those that you have spoken to that
the problems in sri lanka have just been
mounting and mounting for years i mean
it's worth remembering of course that
the government of sri lanka has been in
a pretty fragile position since
rajapaksa was ejected
uh yes
there is this situation has been
building for some will tell you many
years but it has come to a head in the
last year under the leadership of the
rajapaksa brothers not just two of them
there were four in cabinet at one point
as well as one of their sons many people
see this as a nepotistic family firm
rather than a true expression of the
democratic will of the sri lankan people
the primary problem has been the winding
down the depletion of foreign currency
reserves have been several reasons for
that the government cut taxes in a
populist move intending to spread
prosperity what it did of course was
reduced government reserves justice
joe's covid hit that's destroyed the
tourism industry here and there's been a
huge impact on agriculture too as a
result of the decision to cut fertilizer
supplies all of that has seen feud food
and fuel become rise in price and become
short on the street and it's brought
thousands out to protest against this
administration
on a national day of action this is how
police greeted protesters at sri lanka's
parliament
they want the president and his brother
the prime minister to resign
the country faces an economic and
political crisis and the anger that
brought all sections of sri lankan
society to the streets will not be
easily swept aside
this is the police line outside the sri
lankan parliament where protests have
been taking place for more than 24 hours
now tensions have risen through the
afternoon and the police used tear gas
and these water cannons to push the
crowds back that worked for a while
many people are not ready to go yet
this is one reason they're protesting
fuel shortages are a daily routine here
petrol and diesel a precious commodity
that the former energy minister sacked
for criticizing government policy said
sri lanka may soon be unable to afford
in near future we have a risk of being
run out of
all kind of all kinds of fuel
what would be the consequences for the
people well
you know immediate situation man without
blood
economy would die
situation is terrible basically sri
lanka right now has no foreign currency
results whatsoever in coming months
definitely there will be a food shortage
how soon could sri lanka start to run
out of food
one to two months
it's a frightening prospect of course
it's very frightening
[Music]
the focus of public anger
home goater is the slogan of the
opposition movement and there's been a
protest camp outside his office for the
past month drawing young and old poor
and professional all appalled for their
country's descent
people
can't afford to get their basic
medicines and not not even even
at a price which they will need to pay
there's no medicines available
at hospitals they turn back people
saying go get the medicines for the
pharmacies and they are even if they go
to pharmacy there's no medicines
available i believe that uh this is
going to affect every single one of us
eventually and uh you know because of
the nepotism sri lanka has faced so much
of issues and the situation we are in
right now is due to the mismanagement of
our leaders
the president has now declared a state
of emergency to control protests but
only outside help will stop the economy
imploding
what's really striking talking to the
people here in the protest camp and
around colombo and in the hill country
where we've spent a couple of days is
just how eager they are that the dire
straight sri lanka is in is broadcast to
the world we have been asked to let
people know what is happening and to
express the anger across the political
spectrum uh the government now this
state of emergency that's been declared
will give the president and the prime
minister more power to suppress the
protests we've just seen there but if
sri lanka is to get through this it is
going to need outside help you might be
able to make out the cranes at the
colombo port complex behind me there
beyond that is the oil terminal sri
lanka has less than 50 million dollars
of usable reserves it can use to buy
commodities that's not even close to
enough to pay for the
single tanker of fuel to keep the
economy moving so sri lanka is to get
through this crisis and avoid a real
dissent into hardship it's going to come
through that port it's going to need the
outside world to help and that is going
to need people to look beyond the
domestic disputes that is causing such
frustration and anger on the streets
here
absolutely okay paul really appreciate
the reporting thank you for that
now north korea is reported to have
fired yet another ballistic missile the
japanese coast guard says that the
missile fell into the sea north korea
last tested a weapon on wednesday
at least 22 people have been killed and
dozens have been injured after a gas
leak caused an explosion at a hotel in
cuba
the blast destroyed the outer walls of
the havana hotel a child is reported to
be among the dead
he was president called the incident a
tragic accident a rescue operation is
underway to try and find anyone still
trapped
all right let's return to the northern
ireland assembly election and bring in
the editor of the political website
slugger o'toole mcfiltey for his
thoughts on what's happening in northern
ireland right now good morning to you
mick thanks for being with us here on
sky news so uh look counting is due to
get underwear in about an hour and 15
minutes time what are your thoughts on
what we see come out of the results
today
yeah well just in context we have a
particular argus form of uh
proportional representation so
accounting actually started yesterday so
we've got some of the headline figures
we know really quite a substantial
amount about the various fortunes of the
different parties um and we know uh
really that what we thought was going to
be true at the very beginning of the
campaign is that it was shin fans night
um
but the only thing that surprised us i
think was the scale of the gap now
between them in terms of the proportion
of votes
and uh the the sdlp
so um you can see there from your screen
29
uh 23
you go back five years of the equivalent
um election um
there was only one percentage point
separating the two and the dup was uh
one point ahead of uh shinton so this is
quite a substantial it's not just that
chimpan has beaten uh the dup it has
beaten the dup quite substantially um
and i think there will be some
consequences
another thing you'll see if you go
further down that table though is that
what's happened in the middle is there
is a consolidated consolidation of the
vote around the alliance party which
caused the green party two seats broadly
in that kind of same territory
it's also um
been disastrous for the nationalist sdlp
that's the party of john hume uh and
slightly less so i think for the uh
david trimble's old party uh the old
street unionist there who's vote
proportion held up and we've had some
good results in some places and
disasters and others but what you're
seeing there is now
three sections three broad sections of
the community now you've got this rush
but we don't have loads of time i do
want to get you another question really
quickly about the alliance party because
um you'll have to explain to our viewers
as quickly as you can that obviously um
the first minister and deputy first
minister are chosen from the two
communities in ireland but seeing this
alliance party do so well is there any
talk about trying to change how those
rules work i mean the alliance party
could at one point make its way into
second place couldn't that no absolutely
and there is talk about it there has
been talk about it in the terms of the
good friday agreement itself after five
years it was supposed to be a
substantive review it's never happened
what's really happened is that the two
big parties have negotiated a settlement
that keeps them in power almost
permanently and remember this
although the designations are going to
change so if these guys ever take office
under these terms the terms of this
election
uh shin pain will be the first minister
and dup the deputy first minister these
are twin bosses they're tied together
like siamese twins one of them can't do
uh can't blow their nose without the
other one's permission so in many
respects although the cosmetics of the
situation have changed
the substantial political reality hasn't
and the the alliance party's issue is
it's a very long way back from
challenging either of those two big
beasts yeah the impasse is not going to
be broken just yet is it very
interesting time to head okay mick sorry
we have to cut it short there but thank
you so much for being with us this
morning we'll speak to you i'm sure the
next few days all right let's take a
look at the uh papers this morning afwa
and dawn are with us again hello again
to you afghan dawn lovely to see you in
my big screen all right let's start off
with the front page of the express dawn
this is one for you um
i'll just read it out bullish bar is
back on track as red wool keeps faith is
that right yeah absolutely yeah well
done uh kamali this is i'll pick this
one up because it's very interesting the
difference that the newspapers have
treated the the story about the tourists
losing seats in london and the south and
as you've just read out the express is
rather boris as they always are and
boris would literally have to kill
somebody before they were negative about
him meanwhile if you go over to the
guardian it's johnson blame for tory
election votes but i picked these
stories because they're both using
pictures of boris johnson a visit to a
school yesterday field end primary
school
in his oxford and rice lip constituency
where he spent time with a group of five
and six-year-olds drawing pictures of
the queen for her jubilee and these are
all could be displayed on the wall and
you know he signed his and you know
frankly the kids pictures were better
just saying that just putting that one
out there um so but that was that that
was interesting but i mean it's it's
it's it is interesting the way it's all
treated differently and it's sort of
like you know he's emboldened as a red
hall though to stick by him and then
it's like oh but in the south it's not
maybe so good but the pictures i love
with him with the kids and as i said
there's one in the express of him
looking all this is my picture
and then the guardian the views from the
same set of him going oh
head in hands like that so it's just the
the difference in the way this election
is being reported you can take pretty
much whatever you want from it but
basically it was a bit of a disaster
wasn't it
well perhaps i mean nothing's hard we
didn't think it was quite a disaster
i've got the pictures here yeah you've
got boris johnson on the express hands
on hips double teapotting and then in
the guardian ah
here we go there we go i think we can
probably see that there boris johnson
with his head in his hands that's also
another
the picture is there on the front page
of the ft as well it really is a a
really great telling of the uh
of the story of the night from two
different outlets all right let's let's
carry on then afterward we're gonna go
inside the guardian now page two um this
is all about covered vaccinations tell
us uh why this story jumped out at you
well yeah so this is a story about
clover vaccinations for a younger people
in the guardian reporting
that the jcbi has said
that young people may not need um a
fourth vaccine so we did have a spring
booster program which was for over 75
some people who are more vulnerable
there's talk of an autumn booster
program as well perhaps for the same age
group but yes this story is saying that
healthier young people in the uk may
never be offered another private job
after having the first two and then the
booster uh saying that because of the
variance and the vaccines are around at
the moment people who have i quote not
yet reached middle age who are healthier
and younger may not ever need this
fourth boost of vaccine also the jcvi is
saying quite interestingly towards the
end of this article that um an infection
would probably give a younger person the
same number of antibodies in the same
number the same amount of protection
excuse me that a vaccine would offer not
saying that younger people should go out
and deliberately get infected but
basically saying that that level of
protection is the same that you would
get from a vaccine so it looks like
younger people those who haven't reached
the middle age yet probably won't be
offered a fourth coated vaccine yeah and
dawn just coming on that we've only got
about a minute and a half left until we
have to go to break you are back next
hour uh and this about young people and
kovid jabs it's not bad news pretty good
news we needed some good news about the
pandemic because there was a line as
well the other day that um case numbers
are coming down dramatically
absolutely it it does appear
to be good news around case numbers are
coming down and you know the the other
side of that is oh we're not testing
ourselves as much but hospitalizations
are coming down um deaths are coming
down slowly and you know there are sadly
still people dying we must never forget
so many families have suffered um and i
do wonder going back to the election
again
how much the way that the government
handled kobed has to do with that i
don't think it's much partygate and be a
gay it's the cost of living and i think
the way that the kovid pandemic was
handled by the conservative government
at the moment but there is good news and
it's a sunny saturday morning so it's
really nice to have some something nice
to talk about for a while yeah exactly
not have that existential dread hanging
over as of a pandemic
guys thank you